is eight years the Carolina head coach
and he has a new guy to sign his checks
he is Ron Rivera back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you coach
don't cry Trish our thing where have I
found you you driving around the
Charlotte area right now yeah I got I
gotta run a quick errand with the
players you know Paige - okay so you're
running it is this that part of the
Rivera honey-do list that's going down
right now
no actually it's not she's uh she's
actually out of town so I don't have a
big list Oh
so they bachelor party at the Rivera
household I like it let's go you know we
got we got that home security systems
we've got the built-in camera so we got
nothing like that all right so have you
spoken to the supposed expected new
owner of the Carolina Panthers yet I
haven't spoken to mr. Tepper I did have
an opportunity to meet him during the
whole process several probably about
five six weeks ago okay and what do you
think do you think there's gonna be any
changes anything other than just uh I
guess status quo what it was a lot
what's it like talking to somebody that
might change a culture in a way what was
this thing you know he's a very
intuitive man you know he's been
involved to a degree with the Steelers
he has a sense in the field for astra
mendes questions you know I did a
presentation on the team and he seemed
to answer those I mean Jimmy asked those
questions and you know and listen to the
answer so uh you know I again I believe
the man has a feel for tonight I look
forward to working with them what is a
presentation for a prospective owner
look like what was that about
well just basically breaking down the
football team you know what the
philosophy is you know what the
direction is what we have in terms of
players we talked a little bit about you
know where we were headed and free
agency in the draft one when we sat down
and went through that okay and so but he
you know there being a minority owner of
the Steelers I mean he knows who Cam
Newton is right he knows pretty much oh
yeah okay and all that good stuff so how
much contact do you have with Cam
at this time of year well it's kind of
cool cuz you know now we're in phase two
so we got the players here and you know
they meet in the morning and then they
go and do their workouts you know we uh
we meet the the offense meets first of
all the defenses out on the field and
then they flip-flop and then then the
officers out on the field defense
meeting but yeah we get to interact with
the players uh you know for the most
part every day and it's cool it really
is it's kind of good to see everybody
see the direction that I believe we can
be headed and I feel really good about
the draft we had so how different will
the offense look with north turner now
at the controls coach thing I think that
people understand is that you know for
the most part this offense when Rob
Kazinsky was our original offensive
coordinator came from from from North's
background because Jed had have worked
with with coach and and for the most
part was installing what you know
North's basic philosophy of football so
it's kind of getting back to the
original roots of who we are as a
football team offensively now of this
this question is asked with the ultimate
respect for Norv son who is the
quarterbacks coach I mean and I'm not
suggesting at all with this question
alright I'm infusing this guys with this
caveat infusing this and all as saying
that he didn't deserve the job but what
I'm asking is as a head coach when a
offensive coordinators son is the
quarterbacks coach is there any concern
what if cam and the quarterbacks coaches
starts grinding gears like quarterbacks
coach hiss and and quarterbacks do I
mean is there any concern on that front
oh well no because feel Scott was with
us to begin with he's got a background
with which some of our players got a
background with with camp he was part of
the staff when we when we brought when
we drafted camp so he's very familiar
and so was almost uh you know one of
those things that you're looking for a
quarterback coaches he looked for a guy
that's got submit from some familiarity
with the offense but also familiarity
with your players and that's what we got
we got a guy that has both so we feel
pretty fortunate to have him back Scott
he's done a great job already his
relationship with Cam seems to be very
strong already and now I'm not worried
about that when the wheels start to
grind a little bit in fact I kind of
expected to happen at some point just
because you know guys there are
competitive by nature and you know
everybody wants to do well everybody
wants to win well and getting nervous is
great again as any coach can have for an
offensive coordinator how much
arm-twisting did you have to do to get
more to take the gig coach well it was
interesting because uh you know I called
coach and we talked a little bit and the
biggest thing he says like I gotta check
with the wife to make sure she's on
board and call me later that afternoon
and it was great because yeah I had
worked for provide coach for him for
four seasons and you know and quite
honestly it was one of the best times I
had coaching I really enjoyed my time
with him and and things went really well
you know we were fortunate we had we had
you know we had we had four winning
seasons while I was there and I really
appreciate it you know his knowledge of
the offensive side of the ball Ron
Rivera Panthers head coach joining me
here mid-may on the Rich Eisen show what
do you think about the new rule change
coach about using the crown of your
helmet to initiate contact again the
owners are gonna meet next week to put a
little bit more meat on the bones here
I'm just be honest with you a little
genuinely concerned that a quarterback
on a sneak or a pulling guard ten yards
down the field is going to nullify a
play that doesn't deserve to be
nullified in the sake of player safety
which is obviously what we're looking
for here are you concerned about the the
adjudication of this rule when it does
get implemented not necessarily because
again sitting in those meetings that
we've had it we had at the combine isn't
the owners means and listening to the
explanation I think once it's all put
together it'll make a lot of sense to
everybody
certain situations certain circumstances
in games you know those things you won't
have to worry about
in other situations other circumstances
you most certainly do have to worry
about it and again those things all be
mapped out hopefully we'll get all those
you know all those things worked out in
this next owners meeting and and we'll
get the directive and and again I really
do I think you know when people see it
and understand it which it will be
forthcoming I think everybody go can I
get what they're talking about I see
what they mean you know and again I
really do think it is it is for the best
as far as the league is concerned
I think people will understand it and
get it can you give us a little bit of a
insight on what we're we're unfamiliar
with right now that will make this a
little bit more understandable well I
think it's really about about whether or
not a player Spears another player you
know when he lowers the head and and and
and attacks a player whether it's a
blocker or it's a it's a runner or it's
a tackler that the yes-man is what
really the referees are looking for is
that as opposed to guys who come in in
an improper football position and in in
a good body alignment and make contact
so it's going to be interesting to see
how all that comes out but I really do
believe once everybody sees it
everybody's gonna be ok I get it
would you be up for having an instant
replay safety net for this making
15-yard penalty x' for this or any other
15-yard personal foul reviewable for you
to throw a red challenge flag as a head
coach in this league well that's one
things I think that they're obviously
gonna discuss and decide upon and you
know as we go through this you know we
will you know there will be some some
some things that most of you do have to
come into play and we'll see how that
goes so would you would you like it I
mean as a head coach who has yes I would
again I just you know if we're gonna
eject a player or somebody I want to
make sure that that exactly what we
think we saw we saw okay and look head
coaches have enough headaches trying to
figure things out in this league and
wonder what players might be up to when
they're off the clock so I'm intrigued
on your reaction to the Supreme Court's
ruling that might put sports gambling
front and center in states across the
country
gambling on the wins and losses and the
yards gained of a team like yours yeah I
mean that is also going to be a concern
but you know hopefully they'll work
something out and get things worked out
the right way it is something that you
know that will obviously have to pay
attention to but hopefully it will be
you know it'll be done the right way
okay how's how's uh how's it Kuechly
doing coach how is he doing great he's
having a good offseason okay um you know
and just just excited for you know for
everybody to get back going and and look
forward to when we get to start phase
three of the OTAs phase three okay so
walk me through it phase one is what
what's phase one the the draft it's
really just conditioning okay the most
part with meetings phase two is if we
start introducing offensive defensive
plays on air and then phase 3 we come
together and we compete offense versus
defense and uh you know in kind of a
it's an it's in a non equipment practice
so they have on for safety is really
this - helmet okay in phase four is
training camp is that what that is
absolutely not even part of phase it's
just training - okay so the I was about
to say winning the Super Bowl what
phases that what phases winning the
second that's the goal that's the
ultimate okay coach really appreciate
the time you take care of drive safe
around there okay I got your it's
appreciate you you got us Ron Rivera
head coach of the Carolina Panthers the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience